bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end l'émission consacrée aux
loisirs aux idées de sorties tout de
suite à le sommaire de votre émission
l'exposition isola nova est programmé
jusqu'au 8 novembre à l'espace richaud
de versailles l'artiste ficales ans nous
présente à travers des clichés une
venise imaginaire et détail dans ce
magazine sorti la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet organise pour la cinquième
année consécutive des après midi d'été
au far west
les enfants peuvent se déguiser
reportage a su dans cette édition
musique le vélizy un bob castel pianiste
des grosses têtes de rtl avec philippe
bouvard vient de sortir son dernier
album baptisé couleur chanson vous
recevront dans quelques instants sur ce
plateau
et puis en fin d'émission l'agenda
sportif du week-end dans le département
il y aura notamment du handball avec les
féminines de montier bretonneux et le 6e
tour de la coupe de france en football
on débute ce 7,8 week-end avec une
exposition située à l'espace réchaud de
versailles
isola nova présentée jusqu'au 8 novembre
l'artiste philippe caron nous présente
16 composition photographique d'une
venise imagine entre documents et
collages et images sont signés à patrick
jacques de dixmude philippe calandre au
photographe d'origine pressé mode a
souhaité se distancier de la réalité en
recréant des images connu pour ses
photos montages de zones industrielles
cet amateur d'architecturé propose une
nouvelle série de compositions autour
d'une venise onirique au fil des années
je me suis un petit peu lassé de la
réalité j'ai décidé de recours de
reconstruire ma propre réalité
en allant vers l'utopie pourrait bien
cette photo une composition qui part de
plusieurs images de plusieurs fragments
je dirais avec ses différents fragments
j'ai géré composer une image qui paraît
être une véritable image mais qui n'en
est pas une
à partir de clichés de bâtiments réels
réalisés à venise avec un argentique
philippe calandre propose au bout d'un
an de travail
cette composition photographique deal
fictives
ces images sont obtenus par photomontage
sur ordinateur avec toujours le souci de
respecter la direction de la lumière la
difficulté dans sept à ses prises de vue
était de combiner deux types
d'architecturés opposé c'est à dire
larchitecture de venise
additionnel avec tout ce que cela
comporte dans les ornements
élu notre architecture qui est celle que
l'on cache le plus souvent qu'il
architecture le porto marghera qui la
ville industrielle à proximité de venise
et le but était de joindre ses deux
architectures cette exposition présentée
à l'espace richaud de versailles
jusqu'au 8 novembre a été commandé
initialement par l'architecte jean
michel wilmotte pour sa fondation
vénitienne
nous passons concours photo organisé par
l'association u r 16 en partenariat avec
tv fil 78
je vous rappelle le concept les
téléspectateurs ont envoyé leurs clichés
par mail un jury s'est ensuite réuni
pour déterminer les gagnants
pour cette première nous avons reçu une
soixantaine de clichés sur le thème
couleurs d'automne pour nous parler de
ce concours nous recevons sur ce plateau
claude chose le président de l'uir 16 la
fédération photographique de france
bonjour bonjour alors une soixantaine de
clichés pour ce premier concours est ce
qu'on peut on peut dire que c'est une
réussite est ce que vous êtes très
satisfait écoutez oui moi je suis quand
même satisfait par par le concours et
surtout je voulais remercier tous les
gens qui ont osé envoyer des photos et
surtout j'ai été très surpris si vous
voulez bon moi qui suis photographe
amateur je dirais un peu perfectionniste
je dirais qu'il ya de très très bonne
chose si vous voulez danser dans ces
photos est globalement mais les gens ils
ont saisi si vous voulez l'intention que
nous avions monté ans avec nous avions
monté avec la rédaction de tv fil 78 de
répondre à cette demande et bien sûr que
le mois prochain on fera
nouveau thème donc voilà nous allons
découvrir présent le top 5 de notre
rédaction
nous allons tout de suite commencer par
le cliché de nadine boutin qui se classe
donc à la cinquième place
on le voit apparaître à l'écran est ce
que cette photo mérite d'être dans le
top 5 je pense niveau des globalement le
jury a désigné cette cette photo je
crois que c'est une photo d'automne si
les qui nous montre une certaine poésie
de cette image si vous à travers ses
reflets que cette personne a fait sur un
étang et je trouve que c'est
c'est dans le c'était vraiment le thème
et puis ça nous permet de voyager de
pousser notre imaginaire à sortir un
petit peu si vous voulez de de la
noirceur de l' automne alors on fait de
la grisaille de l'automne à l'heure
actuelle on passe maintenant notre
numéro 4 avec une photo à dany réserve
voit qu'il ya beaucoup de feuilles un
côté sombre comme on peut le voir à
l'écran est ce que cette photo
correspond bien à l'automne
je pense je pense que oui mickaël elle
ne correspond tout à fait à ce thème là
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya peut-être une
certaine similitude avec la précédente
mais je crois que cibler il ya un regard
il ya sept personnes amenées s'ils
voulaient une touche de poésie de regard
à travers ses reflets judy je tiendrai
pratiquement le même discours que cela
la photo précédente mais je pense que
c'est une photo qu'il mérite si vous
l'êtes sa place notre numéro 3 présent
avec une photo qui a été prise à saint
quentin en yvelines par laetitia
guichard on la voit à l'écran la
photographe a joué sur l'émotion
sur cette photo oui beaucoup moi c'est
une photo qui m'a vraiment plu je pense
que je veux on allait discuter avec
l'ensemble de la rédaction lorsque du
classement c'est quelque chose il y
aurait peut-être des petites choses à
améliorer dehors mais qui sont infimes
mais je pense que ciblées y être c'est
cette espèce de poésie avec ses deux
petits robots en carton si vous laisser
quelque chose qui rentre bien dans le
danger dans l'histoire de la
photographie contemporaine aujourd'hui
où quelque part ciblées on n'est plus là
juste pour appuyer sur un bouton mais
aussi pour composer une image on remonte
encore d'une case dans le classement à
la deuxième place on retrouve une photo
de kevin tu auras le photographe a voulu
jouer sur les couleurs
alors là écoutez le bord de mer
d'inspiration l'évasion le regard sur le
sur l'horizon si vous voulez
alors c'est vrai que l'automne oui mais
on pourrait avoir mais je trouve que la
tendance jaune que nous avons dans cette
photo si vous voulez nous montre bien
qu'on est dans cette saison de l'automne
voilà enfin on retrouve à la première
place le philippe le bars
il est donc le grand gagnant de ce
concours en couleurs d'automne c'est
mérité l'autre chose et je pense que
c'est mérité
les magnifiques la lune ciblées de ce
triptyque ce monsieur a fait une photo
lors d'eire donc de l'éclipsé lunaire
qui était juste au moment du démarrage
de la saison dow jones et un
photomontage cesson trop photos qui ont
été assemblés ensemble c'est à dire
qu'il a fait une première photo une
deuxième avec la lune à moitié voile et
la troisième lorsque la lune et aux
sorties qui est devenu tout rouge
je pense que si blaise et c'est un
travail de photographe je pense que ce
monsieur doit être avoir une certaine
expérience ceux ci voulaient dans la
photographie mais c'est quelque chose de
très poétique s'ils voulaient cette
photo unanimement la désignait donc
comme étant la première moi je trouve
qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose même si
elle paraît un peu plus que je dirais
complexe parce qu'il ya cette espèce de
montage puisque il a semblé trois photos
en sorte mais vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
nos appareils photos nous permettre de
faire ce même type de photos tout à fait
facilement que c'était photos favorites
ouais c'était ma photo favorite mais je
crois que vous de même aussi la
rédaction la rédaction de tf1 lui c'est
lui à l'unanimité quand même là dessus
on passe à présent à une séquence que
vous avez enregistré que l'autre chose
une leçon pour améliorer vos photos au
regard de votre coin il revient juste
après avec vous d'accord je vais essayer
de vous montrer en moins de deux minutes
comment un photographe amateur peut
aujourd'hui mettre en valeur ses photos
grâce aux logiciels de post traitement
que sont par exemple lightroom si si si
ou éventuellement photo ap les regarder
sur la première image ce que j'ai pu
réussir à faire grâce à ce logiciel
veille troupe 6 voilà la photo avant
celle qui a été soumise aux concours
et voilà celle que j'ai obtenues en
faisant quelques modifications et si
vous voyez de température de couleur
pour réchauffer les couleurs à regarder
les faits de cette correction vous voyez
que la température de couleurs plus
chaudes que j'ai utilisé
me permet de mieux traduire les couleurs
de l'automne
la deuxième correction que j'ai
effectuée a été faite à l'aide de cet
outil ici de correction locale 1 le
filtre ryan regardez voilà la photo
corrigés voilà la photo avant à regarder
j'ai simplement foncé à l'extérieur
l'image de manière à accentuer l'effet
tunnel de 7 à les examinons rapidement
les trois autres asie mal je vais passer
à la suivante loyer l'image telle que je
vais traiter et voici l'image telles que
je les ai reçus c'est traité avant après
voyez comme j'ai réussi là encore à
faire ressortir la chaleur des couleurs
de l'automne et j'ai éclaircies l'image
l'arrière-plan pour donner beaucoup de
luminosité à cette image la suivante est
un peu différente voici le traitement
que je les lui ai donné et voilà l'image
telles que je les ai reçus voyez comme à
travers les contrastes j'ai réussi à
faire ressortir cette feuille et sa
structure enfin la dernière image en
utilisant toujours les mêmes moyens
voilà l'image telles que je les ai reçus
et voilà l'image telles que je les
rendus à ce logiciel il existe des clubs
de photo club la vision tout à fait vous
avez des clubs dans la région donc sur
sur voisins le bretonneux
en fait sur elancourt rambouillet sur
versailles
dès que des photos clubs qui pourront
vous initier si vous la ce travail
photographique et vous permettre ciblées
de deux par de simples gestes d'arriver
à améliorer les photos de leur donner ce
petit plus qui feront que la photo ci
voulait se distingue donc on termine
cette rubrique par le concours photo
après le thème sur l'automne les
photographes en herbe devront une
nouvelle fois se creuser les méninges
pendant tout le mois pour remporter le
concours quel sera le prochain têt la
clautre chose alors le prochain thème et
d'écouter toujours sur le local puisque
c'est notre
le but de notre dos d'autres
interventions sur tv fil 78
c'est votre regard sur votre ville donc
les photos seront toujours à déposer
donc sur l'adresse rédaction @ tv fils
point com est la date limite de dépôt
des photos c'est pour le 12 novembre
donc à vos appareils
à l'heure actuelle vous avez de très
belles lumières profitez-en pour sortir
pour montrer l'intérêt que vous avez
pour votre ville merci à vous d'être
passé sur ce plateau vous retrouvera le
mois prochain pour la suite du concours
on passe maintenant à notre rubrique à
littérature merci de m'avoir reçu
direction à présent le pavé du canal
comme chaque semaine la librairie il
vous fait découvrir un nouveau roman
cette semaine zoom sur octobre 2e week
end à livres sur l'afrique du sud je ne
vous en dis pas plus écoutez octobre est
un roman de zowie kong c'est une auteure
sud africaine qui est assez peu traduite
en france elle a le mérite d'avoir une
très belle écriture elle est reconnue
par ses pairs et notamment par toni
morrison tendance à encenser tous ces
moments là on suit l'histoire de mercia
qui est une prof de littérature en
écosse avait une cinquantaine d'années
elle vient d'être quittée par son son
compagnon avec qui elle est restée des
années sans vraiment de raison et c'est
l'occasion pour elle de revenir un peu
sur son passé sur ses origines lé sud
africaine elle est partie d'afrique du
sud depuis très longtemps on est en
octobre en écosse
elle déteste l'automne en écosse elle
préfère l'automne en afrique du sud
elle aimerait bien y retourner et elle
reçoit juste à ce moment là la lettre de
son frère qu'il appelle à l'aide
elle le rejoint donc en afrique du sud
et là elle va se retrouver confronté à
tous sont passés à ses racines elle va
redécouvrir ce pays qu'elle a connues
mais plutôt à l'époque de l'apartheid et
elle va elle va prendre en charge ce
frère qui est alcoolique qui a tendance
à être assez violent avec sa femme et
qui en fait ne s'est pas remis de la
relation avec leur père qui était
quelqu'un d'un peu particulier et elle
va surtout endosser un rôle de tante
donc avec son petit neveu qu'elle n'a
jamais connue et ça va être l'occasion
pour elle de transmettre plein de choses
et notamment son amour pour ce pays
qu'elle a dû quitter un peu de force
mais qu'elle regrettait qu'elle a
vraiment vivre découvrir une idée de
sortie pour ces vacances scolaires la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet
organise pour la cinquième année
consécutive des après midi dédié au far
west
les enfants peuvent se déguiser en cow
boys et aux indiens les images sont
signés elodie moines la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet prend des airs
de far west pendant les vacances
scolaires pour la cinquième année
consécutive des animations autour des
cowboys et des indiens sont programmées
tous les jours de 14 heures à 18 heures
dépaysement garanti
cowboys et indiens ont fait ces deux
camps le camp des indiens et le camp des
cobras yoko des indiens on peut trouver
du tir à l'arc
justement des ateliers créatifs pour
fabriquer ses armes et son équipement
des balades à poney et à dos d'âne en
fait comme les petits zambiens comme
petit tonnerre est du côté des cowboys
en fait c'est chercher des pépites d'or
s'entraîner aux lans est fait roger du
lasso s'entraîner sur le cheval
mécanique aussi et s'entraîner au tir à
capturer halak a rallié le coût du
spectacle la traditionnelle attaque de
diligence six animateurs déguisés aux
couleurs des westerns organise un combat
sans merci entre les peaux rouges et des
visages pâles
chef des indiens on a fait une tirade
accord on a gagné et après mon attention
mais le spectacle est génial spectacle
tu es génial après les animations qui a
aux alentours c'est top
les enfants il peut le faire s'ils
veulent ça tourne beaucoup c'est top
c'est quelque chose de simple mais ça
plaît aux enfants
donc c'est c'est très plaisant et en
plus si on peut on plus costumés le
tarif pour l'après midi de 6 euros pour
les adultes et de 4 euros pour les
enfants l'événement attire chaque année
plus de 8 mille curieux une page
musicale à présent avec le avec le
belize hier bob castel
aujourd'hui dans notre rubrique musicale
nous allons parler du nouvel album du
vélizy un bob castel pianiste est
partenaire du comique si milla est
également pendant 27 ans le pianiste des
grosses têtes de rtl avec philippe
bouvard au castel est justement avec
nous en plateau bonjour bonjour à tous
alors je n'ai rien oublié dans votre âme
et moi par contre
j'allais oublier quelque chose on m'a
dit que c'était votre anniversaire
aujourd'hui à merci merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup vers la bizarre si merci
beaucoup
jarno billet sur votre biographie par
contre annoncé vrai souffert aussi
d'accord alors vous êtes ici pour parler
de votre nouvel album couleurs chansons
de la maison disque marianne mélodies
dont qui est sorti en septembre dernier
qui compte treize chansons
est ce que c'est un album sur lequel
vous avez beaucoup travaillé alors j'ai
beaucoup travaillé c'est à dire c'est un
album qui m'a pris quand même sept mois
mais par contre j'ai eu le confort de
pouvoir profiter du studio
d'enregistrement dans des amis qui a
coproduit d'ailleurs le disque avec moi
et j'ai pris mon temps j'ai pris tout
mon temps parce que j'ai eu le plaisir
d'enregistrer mes chansons les chansons
que j'avais composé avec des auteurs
différents comme sim comme jean-pierre
reginal que vous peut-être vos
téléspectateurs connaissent
voilà on écoute justement un extrait de
votre nouvel album couleurs chanson il
est parti ce grand bateau au fil de
longs de
ce grand bateau dont tu rêvais du fonds
démunis il te conduisent ce grand bateau
de par le monde
ce grand bateau dont tu rêvais baer ce
ta vie ou avez vous puisé votre votre
inspiration ans et vous avez énormément
voyagé notamment sur les bateaux de
croisière vous avez pris votre
inspiration sur pendant vos voyages vos
découvertes
oui absolument mais c'est à dire que la
chanson parle d'un bateau là par exemple
on dit les voyages forment la jeunesse
la mienne et bien formés déjà puisque
j'atteinds déjà un âge canonique 75 ans
voilà mais bon beaucoup de jeunes femmes
et jeunes filles me disent que je ne les
fait pas ouais première clause mais
c'est vrai que les voyages sont très
inspirant de toute façon et puis j'avais
j'avais le loisir quand on était en mer
de de pouvoir me composé mémé musique
tranquillement j'avais des jours et des
jours entiers
voilà et dans cet album vous êtes aussi
vous avez vous également puisé dans
votre dans votre carrière avec fly voir
avec sim
également il est certain aussi que la
promiscuité des autres artistes mam a
aussi aidé énormément bien sûr puis
j'écoute je sais coûte beaucoup de
musiques différentes et même les
musiques actuelles même me plaisent
énormément par exemple j'ai une une
chanteuse que j'adore et qui s'appelle
zaz
voilà par exemple loyer pour un monsieur
de mon âge et mesa ça paraît peut-être
iconoclaste mais j'avoue que c'est une
des chanteuses actuelles qui me plaît le
mieux au niveau personnalités en tout
cas et comment caractériser vous votre
musique
ma musique sud disons c'est c'est de la
variété mais disons que je suis
mélodiste
je suis mélodiste c'est à dire je n'ai
pas appris la musique ma musique et
vient de devon oreille musicale quoi
c'est à dire j'ai eu
chances de de jouer de la musique toute
ma vie depuis l'âge de 4 ans je me suis
mis au piano et je ne me suis jamais
arrêtée pour autant voilà et ce nouvel
album c'est le quatrième
on va essayer 13ème album c'est le cas
est-ce que c'est une rupture ou une
continuité par rapport à ce que vous
avez produit avant non on peut pas dire
que c'est une rupture mais par contre le
plaisir que je me suis fait en premier
parce que avant de plaire aux autres il
faut se plaire à soi même c'est ce qu'on
dit en tout cas c'est j'ai puisé de tous
toute cette énergie musicale au long de
ma carrière il est vrai jeu j'essaie de
la deûle a redonné maintenant à au
public
et qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que les
gens qui écoutent votre votre album vous
disent qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'ils
ressentent
ben j'aime j'aime bien quand quand
quelqu'un écoute même mon disque me me
dise ce qu'il en pense que ce soit bien
ou pas bien mais qu'on me dise vraiment
ce qu'on en pense voilà ça c'est ce qui
me fait le plus plaisir et on peut
retrouver votre album
ou alors mon album le plus simple pour
leur trou le trouver ces ou le site
marianne mélodies sur internet ou castel
bob @ laposte.net
je répète castel bob @ laposte.net
merci beaucoup et bob castiel merci de
passer sur ce plateau je rappel l'album
couleurs chanson sortie dans les bacs
on passe maintenant à notre rubrique
cinéma
comme chaque semaine un programmateur
des yvelines nous présente son coup de
coeur aujourd'hui direction l'espace
voir et des clefs sous avec cyril aladom
cette semaine notre coup de coeur et de
dessins animés mun le gardien de la lune
réalisé par benoît philippon et
alexandre est bouillant dans un monde
fabuleux fume une petit faune facétieux
et désigné bien malgré lui le gardien de
l'avenir celui qui apporte la nuit et
veille sur le monde des rêves fait fuir
mais il enchaîne les catastrophes et
donne l'opportunité aux gardiens des
ténèbres de voler le soleil avec l'aide
de saône le fier gardien du soleil et la
fragile du cir nulle part alors dans une
quête extraordinaire qui fera de lui un
gardien de légende
ce film d'animation poétique vaut
vraiment le détour à la fois pour sa
belle histoire et son esthétique hors du
commun
il déborde d'inventivité en termes de
personnages
artistiquement le dessin animé se montre
au final assez singulier et imaginatif
il fera succomber un large public devant
le charme qui ne dégage ce
divertissement absolument féerique et
diablement efficace est un programme
idéal pour une vision familiale
il touchera à la fois petit écran côté
distribution nous retrouvons les voix de
omar sy de l'imitateur michael gregorio
ainsi que de celle d'izia juin
la lune je crois qu'il ya une maîtrise
mais il a fait une terrible erreur en
choisissant cet imposteur reçoit
passé le champion c'est un peu tard
volet soleil
tu sais toi qui devra gérer les
conséquences commune le gardien de la
nuit est à découvrir cette semaine en
famille à l'espace se dit mort et on
passe à présent aux avis des spectateurs
yvelinois sur les sorties de la semaine
très bon film que j'aime bien
fallait le voir parce que ça c'est sarah
cours d'histoire de d'un héros qui est
qu'on soupçonnait pas en plus en version
originale simple et gagnent c'est un
film magnifique avec des prises de vues
extraordinaires
on a une prise de conscience en fait
deux
de ce que ça représente de manière
scientifique et pour nous des
générations à venir
voit plein de choses qu'on ne
connaissait pas parce qu'il ne va pas
forcément voir la antarctique ça nous
intéresse pas pour ça pas forcément
c'est un film très dur je m'y attendais
un peu mais c'est aussi très très belle
histoire d'un film
prenant très bien mis en scène par ce
qui reporte bien les tissement de l'amp
et psychologique et l'interprétation des
couples était extra c'est un film qui
commence durement mais plus le temps
avance plus on se retrouve dans les
comptes dans l'imaginaire et au ca nous
transporte
c'est extraordinaire c'est certainement
un des plus beaux films de science
fiction
est ce que c'est vraiment de la science
fiction d'ailleurs mais c'est très très
bien réalisé c'est passionnant on
s'ennuie pas une seconde
après cette page cinéma ou pas ce rendez
vous sportif du week-end dans le
département
on commence à 200 da sport par un rendez
vous qu'il ne faudra pas manquer ce
week-end handball féminin le choc est
programmée ce week-end à saint quentin
en yvelines avec le match monty aube
retenues contre rochechouart en
nationale une
ce sera très compliqué pour les animaux
tels produits cette année elle vise
clairement le maintien alors que leurs
adversaires vise la montée
la rencontre est programmée au gymnase
alain colas à montigny ce samedi à 20h30
du handball à présent mais cette fois ci
chez les hommes promu cette saison en
nationale 2 le chesnay avait perdu
toutes ses rencontres depuis le début de
la saison
l'hémorragie s'est arrêté le week-end
dernier avec un match nul contre torcy
les chesnaysiens devrait également
réaliser un gros match pour venir à bout
de sully-sur-loire ce week end
chaque point est important pour la lutte
pour le maintien pour les encourager la
rencontre est programmée au gymnase de
nouvelle france ce samedi à 20 heures
on passe au football cinq équipes
évinois sont encore en lice en coupe de
france verse elle jouera notamment à
grigny ce dimanche mais si vous voulez
rester dans le département château et
chatou qui évolue en dh à affronte
viry-châtillon une équipe de cfa la
rencontre se jouera au stade final tu
hérites dimanche à 14h30 sur le papier
cette rencontre paraît déséquilibré mais
la magie de la coupe de france peut
opérer à tout moment un dernier rendez
vous à noter dans vos agendas pour ce
week-end la célèbre compétition la boule
élan courtoise est organisée ce dimanche
de 14 heures à 18 heures au parc des
sports guy boniface à elancourt plus
d'une centaine de participants sont
attendus pour la manifestation le niveau
devrait être relevé les meilleurs
tireurs et pointeurs du département
seront présents
c'est la fin de ce statut ce week end
merci d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve
lundi prochain pour le 7-8 sport d'ici
là passez un très bon week-end